jardi soya une chose c'est que j'ai
envie de vous dire depuis longtemps oui
la dalle pour voue une grande admiration
parce que dans des temps par tellement
lointain se sont à pas et tout ce que
j'évoque dans les débuts de mémoire
c'était de très grands universitaires
qui disaient qu'elles étaient les bons
livres dans des élus après ça il ya eu
les grands critiques
et bien tout ce monde là aujourd'hui
c'est vous tout seul
oh là là quelle responsabilité quels
responsables ont longtemps l'art et les
peaux longtemps car on vous dit mais un
livre il faut car nice on ait parlé
les éditeurs les éditeurs vous assiègent
les les attachés de presse vous font la
danse des sept voiles
il faut être passé chez ardisson et bah
ça y est j'y suis bien marré
alors pour les plus jeunes je vais
expliquer que vous êtes écrivain prix
goncourt 1948 avec les grandes familles
auteur des rois maudits porté à l'écran
par claude barma et plus récemment par
josée dayan
gros succès aussi de librairies puisque
en urss donné vendu 23 millions oui sans
toucher de droit non plus remarquez ça
n'a pas n'importe quoi le tout c'est
d'être lu oui ça qui importe alors
toujours au sujet des rois maudits vous
avez wc l'un de vos [ __ ] mathieu
gallet raconté l'atelier d'écriture qui
a permis d'écrire tueuse à gages voilà
c'était un gentil garçon que j'avais vu
très jeunes parce que j'étais ami de son
père qui m'avait dit il fait rien en ce
moment est ce que tu pourrais un peut
l'aider
vous n'avez pas attaquer quand il a dit
que c'était un atelier à la dumas qui
avait écrit les rois maudits
mais comment c'est moi qui l'avais dit
ouais c'est moi qui l'avais dit
malheureusement voyez vous ça n'a pas
réussi aussi bien du mal j'étais forcé
tout écrire moi-même n'étiez pas content
de ce qu'avaient fait les ans alors
écrivain donc académiciens puis
secrétaire perpétuel est aujourd'hui
secrétaire perpétuelle honoraire de
l'académie française
pas mal toujours fait rigoler comment un
mec est immortel peut être perpétuelle
en même temps pas parce qu'il est un
pléonasme d'accra on a des scoops sur
les nouveaux mots qui vont rentrer dans
l'équipe il vient justement je crois que
ce couple n'y est pas et voilà étant que
maurice sera là dira pas scoop ballon
rond séisme a marre non mais le côté je
suis très volontiers pour l'entrée de
mou nouveau si ce sont des mots bien
formés et s'ils ont une utilité
doch par exemple ce n'est pas
envisageable josh bard est de toucher au
visage a pour nom
non je vous laisse la responsabilité
donc écrivain académicien hommes
politiques vous avez été ministre
affaires culturelles de 1973 à 1974 et
on vous doit la célèbre formule
les gens qui viennent à la porte de ce
ministère avec une sébile dans une main
et un cocktail molotov dans l'autre
devront choisir et moi je me suis jamais
beaucoup marqué ça se sait pas marquer
ça à l'époque
il a défilé contre vous mais bien
souvent il a inventé la fête de la
musique oui mais moi j'ai inventé les
manifestations costumes et oui celles
qui ont été faites contre moi j'étais
directeur du théâtre de chaillot de
maurice druon a donc été à ce moment-là
nommé ministre la culture pour nous à ce
moment là pour les gens de culture les
gens vous incarniez en effet quelqu'un
qui était une sorte de menace qu'ils ont
sur la la liberté de création et c'est
vrai que grâce à vous on a organisé
l'une des plus importantes
manifestations qu'ils soient dans paris
avec ariane mnouchkine avec d'autres
qu'on avait appelé un peu pompeusement
des funérailles de la culture nous
avions traversé tout paris merci de nous
avoir menacé avec lui brainard nous
avons pu nous dresser contre vous et ça
a été quelques mois passionnant vous
savez le monde culturel
cette étape vous y apparteniez mais
c'était avant que vous en preniez la
charge ministérielle le monde culturel
était un peu débridé et il y avait eu
particulièrement l'exposition de 72 ou
georges pompidou avec générosité
d'esprit largesses dix ans un arm même
contestataires représente son époque etc
avaient donné vraiment pleine liberté
aux api et qu'est ce qui s'était passé
la liberté qu'ils avaient eue c'était
pour insulter pompidou alors l'arrêt là
ils râlent eu assez doux la sébile et le
cocktail marin c'est à ce moment là qui
mate
en d2 venir et il m'a simplement donné
ses instructions qui était clair il m'a
dit et maintenant ce que je vous demande
un trois tours de clé il ya trois tours
de clé vous avez eu ensuite trois tours
de manif oui c'est ça mais ça va pas
gêner du tourin mais c'est vrai que à
l'époque j'ai fait quelque chose de
formidable
si vous avez fait classer la garde horse
et parce qu'il était question d'en faire
un hôtel hilton de cet endroit et grâce
à vous la garde horse est restée en
l'état et aujourd'hui c'est le musée du
19e siècle malheureusement vous n'avez
pas sauvé les halles de baltard
ah oui les halles de baltard les halles
de baltard baltard tg oui alors qu'on ne
les détruise pas une architecture
admirable une herbe superbe jeu les
beaucoup regretté c'était avant ma ça ne
se serait probablement pas passé si
j'avais été là bien aujourd'hui vous
militez pour la reconstruction du palais
des tuileries
oui une bonne idée ça aussi coûter de
tous les monuments brûlé par la commune
c'est le seul qui n'ait pas été
réunifiée ouais nous penser sérieusement
morisod et vous pensez que c'est
possible qu'on peut aujourd'hui décidé
de reconstruire à l'identique b
absolument non
techniquement pour est attendue bien sûr
il me semble que ça vaut la peine
et pour combien attendez un devis avant
le sait pas combien pouvez vous le dire
300 millions d'euros assez raisonnables
sérieux par la dette constr en bas on
est face à une armée parce que parce que
les fondations existe à voir sur 20
semaines elles sont très solides
1 nous avons les plans de tout et je
prétends que ça ne coûterait pas un sou
à l'état car ça peut se faire par
souscription nationale et internationale
sur jack vous seriez d'accord pour ça
les gg lui le les papiers de maurice
druon c'est séduisant
je trouve que quand
les habitants de varsovie et de pologne
on reconstruit le vieux varsovie détruit
après la guerre ou quand les habitants
de dresde ont reconstruit drèze massacré
par la guerre c'était évidemment une
expression patriotique
une façon de vouloir nier la la barbarie
bon les tuileries ont été détruites à la
fin du dix neuvième siècle
peut-être que fall et la commune c'est
la barbarie oui enfin je ne pense pas a
pris dans ces engins je pense biya puis
après tu as quand même pas la raison qui
nous conduit à souhaiter cette
résurrection mais il y avait les les
vestiges était bien à ces noms auraient
ils pouvaient être urgent la bêtise qui
a été fait à l'époque je suis d'accord
avec vous quand la troisième république
aurait dû sauver les tuileries
car l'incendié n'avait atteint qu'une
portion du monument voilà donc écrivain
académicien hommes politiques et
parolier de chansons et descendez et
camara
sort des de la paille les fusils la
mitraille des grenades
aux électeurs à la balnéo couteau tu es
vite
os à moteur attention à ton pardo
dynamite
voilà le chant des partisans alors vous
avez écrit les paroles de cette chanson
votre oncle joseph kessel
car monsieur druon n'était pas votre
père c'est ce que l'on apprend en lisant
le premier des quatre tomes de vos
mémoires publié chez plon de fallois
l'aurore vient du fond du ciel alors
vous raconter dans vos mémoires que vous
descendez d'une lignée de juifs russes
visitent des juifs des steppes des
quasars converti c'est quoi des quasars
convertit les quasars il y avait entre
septième et neuvième siècle un grand et
à un grand état au milieu de la rue si
l'état casar qui étaient les turkmènes
en fait c'est un empire marchand et à
l'époque où tous les politistes gay
animiste chamanistes ont été amenés à se
convertir au monothéisme les russes de
kiev ont choisi la religion orthodoxe et
les quasars ont choisi la religion juive
et c'est ainsi que ce grand empire a été
un empire juifs
et puis que les slaves l'ont conquis et
finalement tous les as kenaz ou presque
sont des quasars repoussé sans arrêt
repoussé par les slaves au cours des
siècles voilà voilà
alors à 18 ans vous avez appris que
votre père était en fait lazare kessel
comédien mort de la grippe espagnole et
qui en fait c est tiré une balle dans le
coeur oui et cela par hasard il faut pas
cacher aux enfants les drames qui ont
entouré leur naissance
c'est pas bon parce qu'un jour ils
l'apprennent et ça crée un choc
là vous l'avez appris d'une drôle de
façon vous étiez en train de préparer
votre bac avec un jeune professeur russe
émigré et il parle du docteur kessel
donc et il dit quand son second fils
lazare s'est suicidé et à ce moment-là
l'âge de 18 ans vous vous rendez compte
que votre père pris 7 est suicidé d'une
balle dans le coeur à leur écoute et
leur retentissement a été fort j'ai
gardé la faire pour moi elle m'amène à
dire aujourd'hui que les gens qui
prennent t'excuses de des drames qui ont
entouré leur naissance ou de leur drame
d'enfance
ça m'émeut pas sa sueur monte alors
voilà vous raconter dans ce livre
comment votre mère vous dit un jour à
l'époque j'avais 7 ans d'aller embrasser
votre nouveau papa rené druon week avait
50 ans qui était notaire et vous
respecte énormément il était merveilleux
il était superbe montée bien à cheval
il avait fait une guerre extrêmement
courageuse et c'était pas un
intellectuel
dieu merci car gay qui m'a donné une
colonne vertébrale et puis un jour cet
homme arrivé vous dis mes enfants nous
sommes ruinés
c'était après le krach de 1929 c'est la
fin des rentiers et là vous avez connu
l'adversité
oui prend mauvais tombe et on va vivre
mais c'est pas mauvais alors voilà vous
racontez votre découverte de la
littérature la montée de l'hitlérisme
vous dit évidemment qu'il aurait fallu
arrêter hitler dès 1936 et au moment où
l'art est occupé la la rive gauche du
rhin on envoyait deux divisions
et c'était fini ouais c'est ce jour là
qu'on a perdu la guerre de 40
et puis après il ya munich vous raconter
daladier qui revient de munich il
s'attend à être hué par les gens qu'il
attendait un rapport tout le monde
l'applaudît dit cette phrase historique
quel con ouais ouais voilà alors vous
racontez votre oncle joseph kessel vous
dites qui mâchait du verre il prenait
des verres et oui ça c'est gai les verts
à champagne gtv2 même léger mais il
avait une manière de les briser entre
ses dents et de les réduire en poudre
ouais voilà ils se brisaient aussi les
verts sur la tête très facilement et
c'était 1 1 un modèle et racler ils
prennent beaucoup de drogue
kessel il a pris de la drogue qui n'a
jamais été intoxiqués au vert un peu
quand même été accro au vert non ils
prenaient de l'héroïne
oui il a tout essayé il a tout essayé
puis l'arrêté brusquement il partait à
la campagne écrit il il écrivait un
livre en trois semaines ouais il avait
plusieurs femmes aussi j'ai appris sur
les gens votre bouquin carrément
polygame elle le savait les filles oh
bah oui on bouge ça arrive très souvent
alors voilà vous racontez votre
engagement dans la france libre enfin ça
ça sera pour le deuxième tome 4 tomes
oui oui le prochain os
je vais déjà annoncé nous titres comme
c'est une bonne mondiale comme vous le
vole pas
c'était ma guerre ma france et ma
douleur
j'avais mon fils ma bataille qui était
bien aussi mais je pensais déjà à
vallorbe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors vous avez défendu maurice papon
lors de son procès ce qui est quand même
étonnant de la part de quelqu'un comme
vous qui avait été un des grands
militants de la france libre bree
pourquoi écoutez c'est le procès que
j'ai attaqué je trouvais le procès
absurde et scandaleuse
on ne fait pas juger un homme qui a
d'après un jury d'honneur de l'été plus
grand résistant aux a été reconnu pour
n'avoir pas frais d'acte de
collaboration et surtout avoir rendu des
services évident à la résistance enfin
où le fait par un jury dont aucun membre
n'était né à l'époque des faits c'est
vraiment la mauvaise justice incarner
penser ça jack
non je dois je respecte le d'autant plus
aisément le sentiment de nous vivrions
qu'il a été vous l'avez rappelé à
l'instant une désincarnation forte de la
france libre donc son point de vue
mérite navette respect et considération
mais l'essentiel de ce qu'on peut
connaître du dossier sur papon et qu'il
a été en effet l'auteur de d'actions qui
ont conduit des ddd des gens la mort et
il n'était pas anormal que même
tardivement un procès soit ordonnée
organisé et permettent je dirais aux
différentes générations
je cherche un petit 2 de se remémorer ce
qu'a été le comportement malheureusement
d'un trop grand nombre de fonctionnaires
français de fonctionnaires civils de
fonctionnaires de police de
fonctionnaires de justice et papou est à
lui seul une sorte de symbole de la
collaboration wim on l'a pris pour
symbole
il y avait 80 sept secrétaires généraux
de préfecture
il était l'un des 87 dans les 80
centièmes de déportation de juifs
pourquoi est-ce que sur ces lui seul
d'autant plus qu'après la libération à
la libération
tous les fonctionnaires français sont
passés devant des commissions près bon
c'est vraiment c'est le bouc émissaire
on veut pas dire que maurice druon que
papon n'est pas poursuivi une carrière
il a été nommé préfet de police il a été
mis dans le général de gaulle y est et
maurice fahé maurice papon je veux pas
l'accabler il a quand même été le préfet
de police au cours du mois sans rien
duquel il ya eu des massacres de
manifestants et notamment aux algériens
ensuite il a été nommé a été nommé au
quai applaudissent et auquel vous n'a
été préfet de police il a eu les charges
que ça représente et souvent le courage
il faut sept héros de fonction ne
justifie en aucun cas de ce carnage
je suis bien d'accord mais bon c'était
sharon c'était c'était la dd d aider les
manifestants pacifiques qui ont été
littéralement massacré assassiné jetés à
la seine
c'est indépendant de la collaboration
naturellement d'un et si monsieur pape
ont le mérite quand même pas la
commisération que lundi portée c'est sur
le principe c'est sur le principe du
prof du procès que j'étais en désaccord
complet bien mourir ont pensé quoi de la
france d'aujourd'hui la la france
d'aujourd'hui
ouais elle s'en remettra ah ben ouais
l'année prochaine
[Applaudissements]
d'accord là dessus nous si là dessus
nous sommes d'accord après ça s'est un
peu de votre époque et vous j'aime
beaucoup jacquelin vous avez vu où
serait bien maintenant bah oui mais je
vais vous dire quand même
malgré tout je vais pas aller jusqu'à
voter pour lui or c'est quand même une
analyse de la france d'aujourd'hui qui
est un petit peu réactionnaire par
exemple regretté que la peine de mort et
été abrogée oui écoutez c'est un vieux
vieux principe qui remonte à l'origine
des civilisations celui qui attentent
aux principes sacrés de la cité doit-on
être éliminé pas que la peine de mort
pour des valeurs il n'y a pas que la
peine de mort
un mais mais en tout cas il ne doit pas
rester mais doit pas rester dans la cité
mariale à présent penser m'emprisonner
il est dans la cité ah bon on peut
l'exil et on peut les xix voilà alors là
là si on veut me donner une île entourée
de requin où on mettra où on mettra les
condamnés à mort ensemble et il trouvait
et ils font eux mêmes leurs polices et
ben avoir abordé était moribond
oui si je peux me permettre à m quand
même c'est le bagne que vous décrivez à
l'instant vous savez vous savez ce qu'a
été la monstruosité du bal vous n'avez
pas été assassinés donc vous ne savez
pas ce que c'est qu'un monstrueux ou
gmail est bientôt par une vengeance
la grosse curiosité d'une vengeance
froide
organisé sous forme de la peine de mort
ou ou de l'envoi au bagne et tu est
contraire à l'idée que je me fais de la
civilisation et bâle bon coeur vous
perdra je préfère perdre mais avoir du
bon coeur ah bah voilà
moi je préfère la bonne vous pensez que
dans tous les domaines
je suis un affreux réaction à tunis à
mourouj approche maintenant je vais vous
dire il ya un remède à la situation
mauvaise de notre société
c'est la bombe ben oui elle le ce n'est
pas tout de même ce que je souhaite bien
ce que je souhaite
il y a remarqué retard et ça nous menace
beaucoup plus qu'on ne le dit c'est pas
quelque chose avec lequel il faut jouer
les iraniens sont en train de nous
prouver que nous sommes tout de même sur
un monde dans un monde fragile
je vais vous dire ce que je voudrais
pour la france qui est le pays où l'on
travaille le moins où l'on paye le plus
d'impôts et où les dettes sont les plus
lourdes et où on a des couvertures
sociales les plus écrasante où l'on a
plus que des assistés or des assistés ne
sont pas des gens ni moi j'ai une
proposition à fait oui alors c'est la
dotation universel de nationalité ou de
citoyenneté
c'est à dire
gauche dans un pays qui a la dignité que
devrait avoir la force
aucun citoyen ne devrait être un état de
misère dont tout citoyen a dès sa
naissance recevrez un minimum mensuel
qui assurent ses besoins couverts
nourriture chez quoi et non mais on
bloque les vêtements bien ceux qui
auraient davantage
vous dites vous voulez pas d'assister
sans faire escale dans la cité du sang
peut arrêter de bosser ça m'intéresse
que je supprime toutes les autres
assistants à voir si vous faites
l'économie des actions sociales du
chômage et cetera vous avez de quoi
répartir la même chose à tous les
français depuis le jour de leur
naissance
et bien c'est moderne vous seriez
d'accord avec ça jack
non mais et oui on va gagner du temps
[Rires]
ils devront être est un disque audio
prenons le pour le discours d'un d'un
d'impôt est ici la prado mais la
première partie du discours évidemment
je ne peux pas l'accepter tout ce que
vous dites sur la couverture sociale sur
le chômage elle sur le reste je ne peux
pas l'accepter mais l'instant baudet
dénoncé une idée utopique qu on peut la
trouver dans la cité du soleil ou dans
les ouvrages m'écouter
le parti socialiste est une utopie
carrick a réussi ouais mais prend 20
euros à chaque fois qu'ils arrivent à
convaincre un an alors vous êtes contre
la féminisation des démo présente le une
écrivaine pour vous c'est un barbarisme
c'est un barbarisme mais il ya surtout
une chose c'est la féminisation des noms
de fonction oui des fonctions d'autorité
une femme ambassadeur est un ambassadeur
ce n'est pas une ambassade non c'est la
femme de l'ambassadeur que
l'ambassadrice non c'est oui c'est la
femme de l'ambassadeur ferrero les
boussoles ambassadeurs et ambassadrices
mais une femme alors une femme
ambassadeur pour vous reste à la cuisine
shader à l'ambassade
un ambassadeur comme on appelle le mari
d'une femme ambassadeur à côte merci
monsieur untel ah oui monsieur interview
à bâle
oui on ne peut pas lui donner un air que
la femme de l'ambassadeur peut être
ambassadrices
mais oui le mari d'une femme ambassadeur
nuit les rien à écouter ça c'est ça
dépend de l'usa d'accord c'est l'usager
qui est le grand maître
alors je rêve je continue là dessus la
ministre de la culture sera chargé de
l'exécution est chargé de l'exécution du
prochain décret ouais le décret reste en
application quand tu es gentil loup qui
vient essais et il est la ministre les
femmes en politique elles sont en train
de prendre le pouvoir lors pourquoi pas
et là vous les verrez bon rien turenne
et à pété une durite là tout le respect
que je vous dois
- je dois le respect à une femme c'est
pour ça que je ne vous répondrai pas si
ça vous voulez gueuler et bac de l'est
j'ai la nausée la voix plus forte
mais si ségolène devient présidente de
la république non elle sera président de
la république et les présidents elle est
un président de la république elle ne
sera jamais présidente mais ça ne doit
pas se faire c'est contraire à la langue
française
maintenant les féminisation prix en
docteur professeur écrivaine bon tout ça
c'est de la mauvaise c'est de la
mauvaise grammaire ces derniers horaires
de grammaire car il y à del et d'eysines
ans féminines en français obéit à
certaines règles qui ont dit pas une
recteur un oud une rectrice way morichon
qu'il a raison maurice dont on peut il a
raison ce oui il a raison si si on
considère que c'était la théorie
d'ailleurs de marc fumaroli oui que le
ans qu'en réalité derrière le mot
ambassadeurs ou aux ministres aux
recteurs ce n'est pas le masculin c'est
le neutre c'est le mur
c'est lui en même temps en même temps
c'est aller contre une transformation
vers l'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes
vous vous ne protestez pas si l'on dit
une infirmière vous ne protestez pas si
on dira qu'il doit c'est l'usagé aussi
une doctoresse la doctoresse elle prend
tu es si elle veut simple et docteur
s'ils veulent tuer le peu le dr s éteint
mon kiki est malvenue
le milieu médical ouais un homme qui est
esthéticiens qui et esthéticiens batanes
esthéticiens est un homme qui s'installe
à c'est un maïeuticien
bravo bon on en reste là
je ne sais plus
[Musique]
le toit en quarts
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
faut tirer une carte monsieur brûlant ah
bon le ici cartes entre ici maurice
druon délire tintin faire l'éloge
funèbre de maurice grue l'on a c'est pas
mal oh c'est bien c'est moi qui dois le
faire oui oh
nous voulons perdre un très grand
initial
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu